صباح الخير سهام وطل عليكم اليوم من معمل
صناعه اله السمسميه وبالتحديد من مكه طبعا
اي عود تاريخ هذه الاله لالاف السنين حيث
وجدت في الحضاره السومريه في العراق وايضا
الحضاره الفرعونيه في مصر وجدت ايضا ايضا
نقوش لها في المقابر المصريه القديمه
وكانت على اله الكناره اللي استحدثوها
اليوم تطورت بشكلها الحالي الى اله
السمسميه طبعا اشتهرت ومع الانفتاح اللي
صاير والتطور يعني انتقلت هذه الاله من
مصر الى
السودان مرورا بالاردن وصولا الى السعوديه
ودول ساحل البحر الاحمر لتفاصيل اكثر عن
الموضوع عندما صانع السمسميه الاستاذ مطلق
الحلاس
صباح الخير استاذ مطلق لو تعرفني اكثر عن
السمسميه وسبب تسميتها بالسمسميه على
التحديد
الساحل الغربي في صفه عامه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
سميت بهذا الاسم
نسبه الى
علب السمسم زيت السمسم اللي كانت تيجي فما
كان في العلب كانوا ياخذون العلب هذه
فيسوه منها الاله الشعبيه فاطلقوا عليها
اسم سمسميه
اه في هذا المعمل تقوم انتم بصناعه اله
السمسميه على ايدي شباب سعوديين لو تحدثنا
اكثر عن صناعتها وبما انها قاعده تقاوم
الاندثار في ظل وجود العديد من الالات
الموسيقيه الوتريه
الان صناعه السمسميه اول شيء حفاظا على
عدم انتثارها ولانها اعلى شعبيه
ومحبوبه في المنطقه الغربيه بصفه عامه
وينبع والمدينه
اضافه على ذلك انها همم يعني تعتبر ميزه
من شعبيه لاهل مكه
فبدانا في صناعتها يعني علمنا العام سعيد
الصباغ وولده عادل الصباغ في الطائف
وانتقلت معنا هنا وتعلمناها وانا الان
بدور ينقلها واعلمها اولادي حفاظا على هذه
الاله الشعبيه انها ما تندر والحمد لله
بدانا الان ندرب شباب سعوديين على صناعتها
في الفن الشعبي الفلكلوري حدثني عن هذه
اهميه وخاصه انها مهمه كمان في بدايه اي
فنان شعبي
اهميه ان هي كانت الاله الوحيده في
المنطقه الغربيه
فكان ما يقام اي حافله الا ولازم تكون اله
السمسميه احد الالات الرئيسيه
لا تستخدم الا في المناسبات والافراح
والجلسات الخاصه همم بعيده كل البعد عن
السياسه او ما فيها هذا الكلام ابدا لكن
هي تستخدم همم بشكل رئيسي للمناسبات همم
هنا في المنطقه الغربيه والشهره ناس كثيره
منهم الفنانه القديره ابو سراج وفرقه ابو
هلال هذول هم اللي همم التراث ولا زالوا
مستمرين فيه واحنا ان شاء الله ان احنا
ماشيين في نفس المنوال اللي هم ماشي
طيب بقى في ظل وجود العديد من الالات
الموسيقيه لا تزال سمسميه صن داون منذ
الاف السنين
وانت ما شاء الله يعني بتحاول وبتحيي هذا
التراث كيف لقيت الاقبال عليها وهل فعلا
وجدت الناس لسه لا تبغى تسترجع هذا الفن
يبغى يعني يبغى يكون بصمه في تراثه
من الالات اللي لا زالت متمسكه بمكانتها
كاله موسيقيه همم يعتد بها في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبعض دول الخليفه خاصه
السواحليه همم اللي يشجعنا ان احنا نستمر
فيها اولا اقبال الشباب همم من جيل وراء
جيل وراء جيل همم الشباب اول ما يبداوا
يتعلموا السمسميه همم وهي تعتبر الاله
اللي تسهل عمليه دخول الالات اللي اصعب من
السمسميه منها اله العود منها
البدايه البدايه الشباب اول ما يتعلم
يتعلم السمسميه وفي اقبال من الشباب على
على شرائها والتعامل معها مما جعلنا ان
احنا همم نبدا نصنع اكثر واكثر واكثر
ويوفر رغبه الشباب
واعطاهم اللي يتمنون
يعني اكثر من اربع الاف سنه ولا تزال هذه
الاله مقاومه لكل الاندثار ومع كل وفي ظل
وجود كل هذه الالات لا زالت السمسميه لها
مكانتها في السعوديه سواء في السعوديه او
خارج السعوديه
وتظل اله تراثيه محبوبه لدائها للحجاز
شكرا من مكه مراسله صباح العربيه حنان
البخاري شكرا لك يا حنان